Hi, Giura
Hi, Oded
how are you?
I'm fine
I'm on my way to you now
The team will join us later for lunch
We'll show you a great new feature
You will like it
I am waiting for you
Sesame started about five years ago
I did not know I would work in this area
And appeared on TV to display the game
Developed and controlled by head gestures
You move your head to chase the character
A day later, I received a phone call
The caller told me he was helpless
About moving his hands or legs
He asked me to make a smart phone that he could use
He came and looked at me to tell me
That he founded a new company
And that it was not ready for change at the moment.
I told him that this would be a lot better
To help the world
I was convinced by my point of view.
My company has provided a new perspective
About what technology can do
And their ability to change lives
Allows me to modify the Android operating system
Make more innovations than I imagined at first
The first time I used this phone was more like magic
I almost jumped out of the seat
You have to say "open sesame"
Open sesame
This is how the phone is opened
From here, you can run any application
Just move your head
I was frequently asked to introduce the self-image feature
I think it's fun
It is not a normal company
You will encounter days when you cry of happiness
Because you have made a great known for the life of someone who needs to help you
The app is now available on Google Play
Everyone can download it all over the world, and that's what happens
One of our great application users, Alex Friedman
I met him when one of the acquaintances was
At this time a campaign is beginning in Israel
To raise awareness about people with disabilities
Sesame was used distinctly
There are things I do that I could not have done before
I could not handle my smartphone
My life changed completely
The app helps me work and in my personal life
The app is fun because it allows us to communicate throughout the day
Google Play Console gives us many tools
To better meet our users' needs
We know appropriate and inappropriate applications
And through assessments and reviews
We can actually communicate with users
And take advantage of all the wonderful features
Provided by the Play Store
The most important feature provided by Sesame
Is to enjoy life and communicate
User success is not just a number
Success is the fruit of a full life with its various details and events
These successful people join us in supporting our continued success.